now that we have hopefully a decent
understanding of the squeeze theorem
we'll use that to prove that the limit
I'll do it in yellow the limit as X
approaches zero of sine of X over X is
equal to one and you must be bubbling
over with anticipation now because I've
said this so many times so let's let's
do it it's actually we have to go with
obviously dig out our trigonometry and
it's actually a visual proof so let me
draw at least the first and fourth
quadrants of the unit circle I'll do
that in magenta magenta let's see so let
me see if I can I should draw it pretty
big let me see I just draw it like quite
big let me see I'll draw it like that
it's close enough and then let me draw
out the axes so this is the x-axis would
look something like that
sorry that's the y-axis there you go
and then the x-axis something like that
that's our unit circle there you go now
let me draw a couple of other things let
me draw a well it is a radius but I'm
going to go beyond the unit circle so
let's go like right there and draw a
couple of more things just to set up
this problem nope that's not what I
wanted to do I wanted to do it right
from this point right like that and then
right from this point I want to do this
and then I want to draw another right
from that point I'm going to do that and
now we are ready to go so what I say
this is the unit circle right so if
that's the unit circle what does it mean
it what so it's a circle with radius of
one so the distance from here to here is
one and now if this is an angle X in
radians this is angle X and radians
what's the length of this line right
here what's the length of that line well
by definition sine of X is defined to be
the y-coordinate of any point on on the
unit circle so this is sine of X right
so this is sine of X I'm going to run
out of space let me draw an arrow so
this is that right there is sine of X
now let me ask you a slightly harder one
what's this length right here what's
this length well let's think about it
what is tangent let's go back to our
sohcahtoa definition of tangent right
Toa tangent tangent tangent is equal to
Toa opposite opposite over adjacent
right so what is the tangent of X
tangent of X well it would be equal to
we could take this it be if we say that
this is the right triangle it would be
this length the opposite over the
adjacent right so let's say let's call
this length over here let's call this o
4 opposite but what's the adjacent
length
what's this base of this larger triangle
what is the unit circle right so the
distance from here to here that distance
is also going to be 1 right because it's
just a radius again that's 1 so opposite
over adjacent is equal to the tangent of
X but opposite over adjacent adjacent is
just 1 right so the opposite side this
side right here it's going to be equal
to the tangent of X or another way of
saying it tangent of X is equal to this
side over 1 or tangent of X is equal to
this side so let me write that down
that side is equal to the tangent of X
tangent of X now let's think about the
area of a couple of parts of this this
figure that I've drawn here and maybe I
should have drawn a little bigger but I
think we'll we'll be able to do it so
first let me pick a relatively small
triangle so let's do this triangle right
here I'll trace it in green so this
triangle that I'm tracing in green what
is the area of that triangle well that's
going to be 1/2 times base times height
so it's 1/2 1/2 times the base which is
1 right it's this whole triangle and
then what's the height of it well we
just figured out that this height right
here that this height is sine of X times
sine of X so that's this green triangle
here right now what is the area of not
that green triangle let me do it in
another color let me do it in I'll do it
in in red what is the area of this pie
this pie right here that pie hope you
see that that's not a different enough
color so this pie right here or I'm
going there and then I'm going on the
arc so it's a little bit bigger than the
triangle we just figured out right it's
always going to be a little bit bigger
because it includes this area between
that triangle and the arc all right what
is the area of that arc well if this is
if this angle is X right it's X radians
what is what is what fraction of that is
that of the entire unit circle well
there are two pi radians in a total unit
circle right so this area right here is
going to be equal to what it's going to
be equal to the fraction x is of the
total radians in the unit circle right
so it's X radians over two pi radians in
the entire unit circle so that's kind of
the fraction that this is of you know if
you did in degrees the fraction that
this is over 360 degrees times the area
of the whole circle right this tells us
what fraction we are of the circle and
we're going to want to multiply that
times the area of the whole circle well
what's the area of the whole circle well
area is PI R squared
the radius is one
right so the the area of the entire
circle is just PI right PI R squared R
is 1 so the area is a circle so the area
of this wedge right here is just going
to be equal to these PI's cancel out is
equal to x over 2 so that that first
small triangle that was just that green
triangle we did is sine of X 1/2 sine of
X that's the area of that green triangle
then the slightly larger area of this
wedge is we figured out just now it's x
over 2 and now let's take the area of
that larger triangle of this big
triangle here and that's maybe the most
obvious is 1/2 base times height so
that's 1/2 the base is 1 again 1 times
the height is tangent of X its equal to
1/2 tangent of X now it should be clear
just looking at this diagram no matter
where I drew this top line that this
green triangle has a smaller area than
this wedge which has a smaller area than
this large triangle right so let's write
an inequality that says that the green
triangle the area of the green triangle
so 1/2 1/2 sine of X that's the area of
the green triangle it's less than this
the area of this wedge so that's x over
2 and they're both less than the area of
this large triangle right which is 1/2
tangent of X now what is this true this
is true as long as we're in the first
quadrant right as long as we're in the
first quadrant what it's also almost
true if we go into the fourth quadrant
except then the sine of X becomes
negative the tangent of X becomes
negative and X becomes negative but if
we take the absolute value of everything
it still holds in the fourth quadrant
right because if you go negative as long
as we take the absolute value then the
distance is still hold and we still have
positive areas and all of that kind of
things right so let's since I want to
I'm my goal is to take the limit as X
approaches zero and I want to take the
limit in order for this limit to be
defined in Gen
it has to be true from both the positive
and the negative side let's take the
absolute value of both sides of this and
hopefully this makes sense do you if I
were to draw the line down here and this
would be the sign of X and I would be
the tangent of X as long as you took the
absolute value of everything you're
essentially just doing the same thing as
in the first quadrant so let's take the
absolute value of everything and that
shouldn't change anything especially if
you're in the first quadrant and you
might want to think about a little bit Y
doesn't change anything in the second
quadrant so we have this inequality
let's see if we can play around with
this so first of all let's just multiply
everything by 2 and get rid of the 1
halves right so we get absolute value of
sine of X is less than absolute value of
x which is the less than the absolute
value of the tangent of X I hope I
didn't confuse you by taking the
absolute value that original inequality
I wrote was completely valid in the
first quadrant but since I wanted I want
this inequality be true in the first and
fourth quadrants because I'm taking the
limit as X approaches 0 from both sides
I put that absolute value there so you
could draw the line down there and do
all everything we did up there and the
fourth quadrant but just take the
absolute value and it should work out
the same anyway back to the problem so
we have this inequality and I'm running
out of space so let me erase some of
this stuff up here erase erase nope that
doesn't erase ok that should erase okay
so we could erase everything that took
us so far just so we can't forget this
though it gives us a lot of space ok so
let's take this and let's take that
expression and divide all of the sides
you know it has three sides of left
middle and right let's divide them all
by the absolute value of sine of X and
since we know that the absolute value of
sine of X is a positive number we know
that the these less than signs don't
change right so let's do that so the
absolute value of the sine of X divided
by the absolute value of the sine of X
well that equals 1 which is less than
the absolute value of x divided by the
absolute value of
sign of X which is less than what state
what's the absolute value of 10 so all
I'm doing is I'm taking the absolute
value of sine of X absolute value of
sine of X absolute value of sine of X so
what's the absolute value of the tangent
of X divided by the absolute value of
sine of X well tangent is just cosine
over sine
right I'm sorry it's just sine over
cosine so that's equal to so just do
this part right here that's equal to
sine over cosine divided by sine and you
know you could say that this is same
thing as the absolute value of the
absolute value divided by the absolute
value so what what are you left with
well you're just left with 1 over this
cancels out with this that becomes a 1 1
over the absolute value of the cosine of
X so we you might feel we're getting
close because this looks a lot like this
it's just inverted so to get to this
let's invert it and to invert it what
happens well when first of all what
happens when you invert 1 well 1 over 1
is just 1 but when you take when you
invert both sides of an inequality you
switch the inequality right and if that
doesn't make sense to you
think about this you know if I say 1/2
is less than 2 and I invert both sides
of that I get 2 is greater than 1/2
right so that that hopefully gives you a
little intuition so if I'm inverting all
of the sides of this inequality I have
to switch the inequality signs so 1 is
greater than absolute value of sine of X
over over the absolute value of x which
is greater than absolute value of cosine
of X now let me ask you a question sine
the absolute value of sine of x over
well first of all sine of X over X well
that ever will there ever be a time when
sine of X over X is in in this in the in
the first or the fourth quadrant is
there ever time that sine of X over X is
a negative expression when the first
quadrant sine of X is
positive and X is positive so positive
divided divided by a positive is going
to be positive and then the fourth
quadrant sine of X is negative right
sine of X is negative Y is negative and
the angle is negative so X is also
negative so in the fourth quadrant sine
of X over X is going to be a negative
divided by a negative so it's going to
be a positive again so this so sine of X
over X is always going to be a positive
so the absolute value signs are kind of
redundant right so we could write 1 is
greater than sine of X over X and the
same logic in the first and fourth
quadrants and that's where we're dealing
with we're dealing with you know we're
dealing with minus PI over 2 is less
than X which is less than PI over 2 so
we're going from minus PI over 2 all the
way to PI over 2 so we're in the fourth
and first quadrant is cosine of X ever
negative well cosine is the x value and
the X by definition in the first and
fourth quadrants the x value is always
positive so if this is always positive
we can we can get rid of the absolute
value signs there and just write that
and now we are ready to use the squeeze
theorem let me erase all of this down
here now so let me ask you a question
what is the limit as X approaches zero
of the function 1 well the function 1 is
always equal to 1 so I could set the
limit as X approaches infinity the limit
as X approaches PI anything.this is
always going to be equal to 1 right so
as X approaches 0 this is equal to 1 and
then what is the limit as X approaches 0
of cosine of X well that's easy too
as X approaches 0 what cosine of 0 is
just 1 is you get you know it's a
continuous function so the limit is 1 so
we are ready to use the squeeze theorem
as we approach 0 as X approaches 0
function approaches 1 this function
approaches 1 and this function or this
expression is in between the two and if
it's in between the two as we approach
as we have this is approaching what this
is approaching 1 as we approach 0 this
is approaching 1 as we approach 0 and
this is in between them so it also has
to approach 1 as we approach 0 and so we
are using the squeeze theorem based on
this and this and you could say you know
therefore by the squeeze theorem because
this is true this is true and this is
true sine of X over X the limit as X
approaches 0 is equal to 1 so hopefully
that gave you the intuition that that
the you know you can kind of another way
to view it is as we as this line gets
smaller and smaller as it approaches 0
as X approaches 0 that that these these
it this area and this area converge so
the area in between kind of has to
converge to the both of them and if you
want to see it graphically I've graphed
it here let's see let me see if I can
graph this thing show you the graph just
so you believe me so we said that 1 is
always greater than sine of X which is
always greater than cosine of X between
between negative PI over 2 and PI over 2
and of course this isn't defined at X is
equal to 0 but we can figure out the
limit so there we have it this blue line
right here that's the function 1 that's
y is equal to 1 this blue this light
blue line right here is cosine of X and
this is the graph of sine of X over X
and you can see that you know I've
actually typed it in so sine of X over X
between PI over 2 but 2 sorry between
negative PI over 2 and PI over 2 or the
fourth and the first quadrants the red
line is always in between it's always in
between the dark blue and the light blue
line and so and so this is just an
intuition of what happens with the
squeezed there and we know that the
limit as this light blue line approaches
0 is 1 and we know the limit as this top
dark blue line approaches Z
is one and this red line is always in
between it so it also approaches one so
there you have it the proof using the
squeeze theorem and a little bit of
visual trigonometry of why the limit as
X approaches zero of sine of X over X is
equal to one I hope I haven't confused
you